posez lyon votre question on vous trouve
l'info sur le site amazon.ca monsieur
garou a commandé cette impression sur
toile à 127 $ livraison incluse quelques
jours plus tard ups sonne à sa porte
le livreur lui exige 38 dollar à 92
avant de lui remettre le paquet c'est le
prix du dédouanement et oui même si vous
achetez sur un site point ca
il est possible que le vendeur tiers
hébergé par amazon soit à l'extérieur du
pays et selon la loi
si ce vendeur ne perçoit pas les taxes
c'est le transporteur qui va le faire
et au passage y ajouter de jute frais de
courtage
dans ce cas ci les frais de ups
représente presque 25 % de la facture
rien dans la transaction n'indiquait
cela mais l'information existe sur une
des pages d'amazon quelque part bon je
les loue un truc si votre vendeur n'est
pas au pays ouvrez un nouvel onglet
étape et estimer les droits et les taxes
cela vous mènera sur le site internet de
l'agencé des services frontaliers du
canada
et là vous saurez combien ça va vous
coûter pour dédouaner votre achat mais
n'oubliez pas les frais de courtage sont
ajoutés à la livraison et même pour une
simple affiche ça peut être cher non
seulement
[Musique]